so what does it mean to be a seeker
right to be a seeker is to be a restless
mind to be a seeker is to have a fire in
the belly to be a seeker is to be
defined consumed agitated by curiosity
to be a seeker is to want to know the
world to want to map the world to want
to design refine an augment the world to
be a seeker is to love science
inspiration transformation design
creativity to be a secret is to question
dogma to be a secret is to grade you
against the darkness to be a seeker is
to want to scramble the self and
reconstitute to constantly upgrade to be
a secret is to understand that we are
beings made of language we are
alphabetic all the way down we are made
of code DNA is software DNA is language
we are made of language a seeker is one
wants to refine to augment to to author
new languages of being to disclose new
world hoods that is what it means to be
a seeker to rage rage against the dying
of the light
or I'll say it again we will not let go
we will not surrender to be a seeker is
to never never let go what pulls us what
beckons that's what it means to be a
seeker
you